It's a time of great transition in the world
economy and it's crucial that important causes
and problems are not forgotten.
This January, at Davos, our leaders will be
discussing how we redesign and rethink many
aspects of our world.
YouTube and the World Economic Forum are offering
one person the opportunity to join them.
We need big thinkers, people who will stand
up and get their voices heard.
We're opening the doors to Davos to someone
passionate and articulate, fighting for something
that deserves everyone's attention.
What issue do you believe needs rethinking?
How would you redesign our approach to pressing
problems?
If you could rebuild your cause, how could
those at Davos help and inspire you?
We want to hear real stories from people working
on local causes, who want to make these causes
global.
Maybe it's human rights, or the environment,
or poverty or discrimination?
Maybe your cause is education, political freedom
or saving the world's oceans?
Are you ready to stand up on the Davos stage
alongside some of the most influential people
in the world and fight for your cause?
Press record.
Make your pitch.
Upload it to YouTube.
Then submit your video to youtube.com/davos
before the 4th of January 2010
For your chance to be part of the Davos Debates.